bound by flame is a mess it's a mess
with high-minded ideas but it's a mess
all the same by the time the game comes
to a close it's clear that there's a
wide gulf between the experience you
just had and the vision that inspired it
bound by flame is a fantasy role-playing
game about choice the game presents you
with narrative decisions now and again
that effect faction allegiances and
spawn conflicts most of which can only
be solved through swordplay the star is
a mercenary called Vulcan he or she if
you choose a female avatar finds himself
sharing his brain with a growling demon
Vulcans mind becomes rather overcrowded
as a result but at least the demon
grants him the ability to conjure fire
bound by flames most intriguing choices
are those that see you deciding whether
to bends to the demons whims or assert
your humanity the more you side with the
demons advice the more you take on
demonic traits as I face the final
battle I had three sets of curled horns
growing from my blackened head and my
voice had taken on a diabolical Rumble
the consequences of these decisions
aren't just cosmetic growing horns for
example means you can't wear helmets
though you do gain enhanced magic power
regeneration by way of compensation
there are other trade-offs as well but
mutating into a fiery fiend is
nonetheless of delectable experience
there are choices to make and bound by
flames story that have nothing to do
with the demon within but the game's
poor dialogue and bland acting aren't
apt to make you care about anyone's fate
but your own well your ice Lords have
never messed with a powder Master now
have they
if you listen to the rabble who actually
live in the swamps we should head back
to the village now characters are
introduced one after another and many of
them are available as battle companions
they have tales to tell if you ask them
but bare-bones writing communicates only
the essential information without
fleshing out the people sharing it over
time narrative problems compound so
greatly that you can no longer take
anything seriously transitions from
gameplay to cut scenes are jarring with
characters repositioned instantly the
tone seesaws wildly with your
conversation partners cracking jokes at
the oddest moments and Vulcans suddenly
acting like a jerk for no apparent
reason when the final hours asked me to
make a sacrifice I made the decision
arbitrarily because none of this
insanity mattered to me your companions
aren't just boring they're also useless
in battle often following in a matter of
seconds
combat is bound by flames biggest
problem that the fighting is initially
pleasing you can switch between various
stances that let you use a formidable
two-handed weapon wield a pair of
daggers or sneak around and take on dead
enemies by surprise you can also toss
fireballs and infuse your weapon with
glowing flames thanks to your demon
friend
Vulcans muscular swings give combat a
nice sense of heft and the game skill
trees let you customize your fighting
style in sensible ways found by flame
then proceeds to ruin it's promising
combat with a series of choices that
suck out all the fun small areas are
overpopulated with ice spirits lurching
archers and other enemies with
ridiculously large health bars throw
into the mix of companion that you can't
revive in the middle of battle an
unreliable target lock incoming attacks
that always cause interrupts or knock
backs and a camera that can always frame
the action and you rarely find a good
fighting rhythm combat then becomes a
matter of exploiting defects not one of
finding a proper tempo you circle around
bosses for over a minute until your
health replenishes you run away from
battle so that your companion will come
back to life and you try your best not
to lead enemies from their aggravatingly
small leash
ranges lest they return to their homes
and regain all their health
you can help things along by placing
explosive traps and getting your parry
timing down pat but battles remain a
drag all the way up to the
excruciatingly final boss in between
battles you might pursue the game's few
side quests all of which sends you back
into the same lands corridors in which
the main quests occur you may also check
out the game's crafting system which is
its most robust feature various elements
can be combined to make useful items
like health potions or to bolster your
equipment refreshingly you can stop the
craft at any time even in the middle of
combat by RPG standards bound by flame
isn't a very long or expansive game if
you don't consider the battles you must
repeat the adventurers around a dozen
hours or so and there's no true world to
explore unless you consider a few medium
sized levels made up of narrow hallways
to be a world gone by flame has a lot of
ideas but never gives them room to grow
fear not my young friend I don't eat
elves they play havoc with my digestion
so you're not at any risk for me